bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui petit
changement de décor puisqu'on est dans
la cuisine et qu'on va essayer de
répondre à cette question absolument
essentiel qui est pourquoi est-ce que le
pastis devient opaque
quand on l'allongé avec de l'eau
alors le phénomène dont on va parler
aujourd'hui je pense que vous avez déjà
tous pu constater si vous prenez du
pastis pureté qui sort de la bouteille
il est transparent
alors certes il est coloré mais vous
pouvez quand même parfaitement voir à
travers
par contre une fois que vous la longe et
avec de l'eau il se trouble et il
devient opaque
alors ce phénomène il est un petit peu
contre intuitif puisqu'on mélange de
liquide qui sont parfaitement
transparent donc on s'attendrait à ce
que le résultat soit aussi pour
comprendre ce qui se passe il faut
s'intéresser à la composition du pastis
le pastis quand il est pur il effet
d'environ 50 % d'alcool et 50 % d'eau
alors je vous rassure il n'y a pas que
ça sinon ça serait pas du pastis serait
la vodka
oui parce que pour ceux qui ne le
sauraient pas c'est scientifiquement
prouvé
la vodka quelle que soit la marque c'est
juste un mélange pur d'alcool et doha
n'y a absolument rien d'autre
non dans le pastis il ya quelques
pouyenne de trucs qui font le bon goût
et il ya notamment un arôme qu'on
appelle la méthode
alors l'année toll c'est une huile
essentielle qui est extraite de la
glisse et donc c'est cette huile
essentielle qui donne au pastis son goût
caractéristique est d'ailleurs qu'on
retrouve chez tous ses cousins du bassin
méditerranéen comme l'ouzo en grèce
leurs acquis en turquie où la samba en
italie ce qui est important pour la
question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est
le fait que l'année toll c'est une huile
essentielle et je pense que vous le
savez l'huile et l'eau elles s'aiment
pas beaucoup
j'en veux pour preuve le fait que si
vous essayez de mélanger de l'huile et
de l'eau dans un verre elle se sépare
une des raisons pour ça c'est le fait
que lui les plus légères que l'eau mais
en fait c'est pas la raison fondamentale
par exemple l'alcool c'est aussi léger
que l'huile et pourtant si vous prenez
une bouteille de vodka vous voyez pas
l'alcool qui surnage au dessus de l'eau
dans la raison pour laquelle on a ce
phénomène de séparation c'est tout
simplement que l'eau et lui ne peuvent
pas se mélanger ont dit qu'elles ne sont
pas mis cible à côté de ça l'eau et
l'alcool
eux sont mis cible est d'ailleurs
l'huile et l'alcool aussi sont visibles
je vous ai dylan et cole c'est une huile
essentielle donc comme toutes les huiles
elle accepte de se mélanger dans
l'alcool mais elle refuse de se mélanger
avec l'eau alors maintenant qu'est ce
qui se passe pour l'année tonnes quand
elle est dans le pastis et ben dans le
pastis pur ja je vous ai dit à peu près
50 % d'alcool et 50 pour son dos eh ben
pour l'année toll ça va ça fait
suffisamment d'alcool pour qu'elle
accepte de se laisser disperser et donc
les molécules d'anatole sont
parfaitement diluée dans le mélange
alors maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on allonge le pastis et ben vous
ajoutez de l'eau et donc vous allez
changer les proportions du mélange ça
sera plus 50 50 mais ça sera peut-être
80% d'eau et seulement 20 % d'alcool et
l'allan et hall belle et plus du tout
contente et elle refuse de se mélanger
et que font les molécules d'adn et hull
pour éviter de se laisser mélanger eh
ben elle décide de se regrouper entre
elles est de former des petites
gouttelettes d'huile qui seront
dispersées dans le mélange et qui
forment ce qu'on appelle une émulsion et
c'est ça qui donne au pastis allonger
son aspect laiteux
pour comprendre physiquement ce qui se
passe il faut faire appel un phénomène
qu'on appelle la diffusion demi je pense
que vous savez que la lumière est une
onde et donc elle possède une longueur
d'onde qui va de à peu près 400
nanomètres pour le bleu jusqu'à 8 100
nanomètres pour le rouge
et quand une onde lumineuse rencontre un
objet qui fait une taille à peu près du
même ordre de grandeur que sa longueur
d'onde
elle se trouve renvoyée dans toutes les
directions on dit qu'elle est diffusée
et donc qu'est ce qui se passe dans
notre cas les gouttelettes d'anatole qui
sont dispersés dans le pastis allongée
elles font environ quelques microns de
diamètre et donc quand la lumière
visible rencontre ces gouttelettes elle
se trouve diffusé dans toutes les
directions et c'est ça qui provoque
l'aspect laiteux du pastis d'ailleurs
quand je parle d'aspect laiteux c'est
pas innocent parce que la raison pour
laquelle le lait est opaque et blanc
mais en fait c'est exactement la même le
lait c'est une émulsion de petites
gouttelettes de graisse dans de l'eau et
donc c'est à cause de la diffusion de
mise sur ces gouttelettes que le lait et
blanc et opaque et d'ailleurs c'est
exactement la même chose qui se passe
avec les nuages sauf que cette fois
c'est des petites gouttelettes d'eau qui
sont dispersés dans l'air maintenant je
voudrais montrer un petit phénomène
amusant si vous prenez du liquide
vaisselle et que vous vous amusez à
l'ajouter à votre pastis allongée
en touillant un petit peu vous allez
vous rendre compte que le pastis re
devient transparent
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour le
comprendre il faut revenir au cas du
mélange simple d'huile et d'eau si je
prends mon mélange d'huile et d'eau de
tout à l'heure et que je m'amuse à
ajouter du liquide vaisselle en
touillant un peu vigoureusement je me
rends compte que j'arrive dans une
certaine mesure à mélanger mon huile et
mono
cette petite expérience elle nous montre
que le liquide vaisselle il permet de
réduire un petit peu la tension entre
nuit les lots c'est à dire qui les rend
à un petit peu plus compatibles et qu'on
peut dans une certaine mesure les
mélanger maintenant si je reviens sur le
cas dans le pastis allongé qu'est ce qui
se passe quand j'ajoute le produit
vaisselle
j'améliore un tout petit peu la
compatibilité entre l'année toll et
l'eau et donc du coup même dans mon
mélange allonger l'année toll accepte
finalement de se laisser disperser dans
le mélange les gouttelettes d'huile se
casse et donc la diffusion disparaît et
la lumière peut à nouveau passé à
travers le mélange et c'est pour ça que
le mélange re devient transparent
évidemment maintenant il est imbuvable
maintenant vous pouvez vous rendre au
bar pmu du coin fr la version tours de
magie de l'expérience vous mettez
discrètement un peu de produit vaisselle
au bout du doigt
et puis vous allez tout y est le pastis
des gens pour le faire redevenir
transparent effet garanti un an fin au
moins au début parce qu'après je vous
conseille de vous mettre à courir avant
qu'ils les routes
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu vous pouvez m'aider à faire
connaître la chaîne en la partageant
vous pouvez également vous abonner me
retrouver sur facebook sur twitter et
sur mon blog s'appelle sens étonnante
à bientôt
bon je vais pouvoir le boire maintenant